COLT MCANLIS: In this episode
of Cloud Performance Atlas,
we help a semi-aquatic, egg
laying, mammal-based calculator
unravel its dependency problem,
and then we do nothing.
Stay tuned for more.
I was grabbing lunch last
week with a good developer
friend of mine, and
the conversation
turned to lamentations around
the limits of Google.com
as a calculator.
I mean, frankly, it's one of
the more accessible calculators
I've ever used, but I end
up hitting the limits of it
pretty quickly.
It won't even compute
the factorial of 256.
My friend then revealed
that she created
her own version of Google.com
calculator called Platy-Calc.
However, her version
ran on App Engine,
and evaluated the
submitted math expressions
using the Python
runtime, which can easily
calculate the factorial of 256.
To me, this was
immediately brilliant,
and I started using Platy-Calc
as my primary web-based
calculator.
However, I started noticing that
the first request of the day
was always a little slower
than subsequent requests.
Seeing as I've been talking
about cold boot time a lot
lately, I reached
out to my friend
and asked to do some
profiling on the application.
A first look at Platy-Calc
showed pretty much
what I was expecting-- higher
than normal cold boot time.
Now, the code for this
app was really simple.
I mean, there's no global
variables, no locking issues,
and no NDB fetches
in the startup path.
The only thing that
was occurring globally
during boot time was
that it was importing
some complex numeric
processing libraries.
Given the fact that we've
already timed a simple Hello
World app and seen what
startup times look like,
these imports look
like a culprit.
Just as a test, we
removed those imports
and retimed the
startup process, just
to see if App Engine cold boot
time had suddenly regressed,
or if there was some
other issue going on.
Thankfully, we
weren't going crazy,
as our timing showed pretty
much the same startup
behavior as I had seen before.
At this point,
process of elimination
was clearly porting
to the imports
as the source of the
startup time issues.
I mean, there was nothing
else going on in the app.
However, it felt wrong to
simply discard them outright.
We needed more information.
As such, we put together
a small code snippet
that timed how long it took for
each of these imports to occur.
Our profiling showed us
two clear data points.
Number one, the
summation of imports
is easily adding about 1.25
seconds to cold boot time
to the application.
And number two, obviously
some of the imports
were taking longer than others.
Now, number two is really
the interesting point here,
and it's worth taking
a second to discuss.
See, during cold boot
time, your application
will be busy scanning and
importing code dependencies.
The longer it takes
to do this, the longer
it will take before your first
line of code is executed.
Now, some languages can
optimize this process
to be exceptionally fast.
Other languages may
be slower at it,
but they provide
more flexibility.
And to be fair,
most of the time,
a standard application
importing a few modules
is less than impactful.
However, when a third party
library gets big enough,
we start to see
them do weird things
with import schematics that can
often mess up your cold boot
time.
A simple Google search revealed
that some other developers
saw similar import time issues.
So it was clear that
this was the problem
we were running into.
Given the fact that imports
were required for our operation,
our hands were a bit tied with
respect to an elegant solution.
Nonetheless, we came up with a
few ideas to address the issue.
Number one, use a
warm up request.
When the website is
loading from static assets,
send a quick ping to the
calculator service, which
will import the
required modules,
rather than waiting for the
calculate button to be pressed.
Number two, lazy
load our imports.
Python supports this
operation by allowing
global versus local
importing of modules.
So we could move all of the
imports to be function local.
So if you just want
to do 2 plus 2,
you don't have to wait to
import the entire SciPy module.
Only when we detect
some specific keyword,
we'd import those
specific things.
And number three, prune
the dependency tree.
We've had a lot of Stack
Overflow posts and tutorials
about how to manually prune
the dependency tree by either
explicitly importing
sub portions of it
or by doing some fun hacks that
included mirroring the module
and removing the
things we didn't need.
But given all that, we
decided to do nothing.
Yep, Platy-Calc is not a
huge million QPS service.
It's just a small
application used
by a few friends who
really need to compute
large numbers from a
command line interface
for some crazy reason.
So waiting an extra
second every few days
for a query that wasn't
big of a deal in our case,
we decided that's the
right thing to do.
Oh, by the way.
If you're looking for what the
factorial of 256 actually is,
there you go.
Thanks, Platy-Calc.
Now, as much as I'd like to
beat the performance drum,
truth is that
sometimes the result
on the end user for a
particular perf improvement
just isn't justified given
the work needed to fix it.
So remember, every
millisecond counts,
except in the few times
where it kind of doesn't.
[MUSIC PLAYING]